au cœur de Moscou une scène fait son
apparition il manque encore les drapeaux
aux couleurs de la Russie
installez sous le regard de quelques
curieux mais les écrans géants et les
banderoles sont déjà là des banderoles
sur lesquelles ils sont
écritsson le nom des quatre régions
ukrainiennes dont le Kremlin devrait
formaliser l'annexion ce vendredi
bonne ou mauvaise nouvelle dans la
capitale les habitants ont du mal à
savoir
mais ce n'est pas non plus la panique
c'est insupportable il y a beaucoup de
résidents là-bas donc je pense que c'est
une bonne chose nous devons en quelque
sorte être unis comme avant mais
beaucoup ont surtout peur de s'exprimer
sur le sujet ou de ce qu'il pourrait
arriver en cas de désaccord avec le
régime
nous ne sommes pas prêts à faire bouger
les choses nous connaissons très bien
l'histoire et nous nous souvenons de ce
qui s'est passé en 1917 alors
aujourd'hui nous soutenons toutes les
décisions de notre gouvernement
en 1917 a débuté la révolution
entraînant la fin du tsarisme et la
naissance du régime bolchevique menant
en 1922 à la mise en place de l'URSS